now permanent Washington has created a
culture where it's acceptable to lie to
further your own interests just try not
to get caught I should know I served in
Congress for eight years but even when
these politicians do get caught people
just shrug their shoulders and move on
no big deal no consequences few examples
dick Blumenthal lied about his military
service and of course Elizabeth Warren
she lied about having Native American
heritage
so no one should be surprised that the
American people don't trust these
politicians they've got no faith that
those in Washington are actually working
for the people when they're so clearly
working for themselves
now there are new accusations that
George Santos who was just elected to
represent New York and Congress in this
past election has actually been lying
extensively about his own past now he
admits to some of these deceptions for
example Santos acknowledges that he
quote embellished his resume by saying
that he graduated from Baruch College
but he didn't
Santos is also admitted he never
actually worked for Citigroup in Goldman
Sachs even though his website suggested
that he did
additionally Santos once called himself
a proud Jew but in an interview with the
New York Post Santos now says quote I am
Catholic because I learned my maternal
family had a Jewish background I said I
was Jewish
there are other accusations but now we
have the opportunity here directly from
George Santos himself this is his very
first TV interview since these
accusations surfaced George Santos joins
us now
Congressman elect Santos thank you for
joining us today
um the first question I really want to
ask you now that all this has been
revealed is what does the word integrity
mean to you
well Tulsi thank you for having me you
know
um so to answer your question Integrity
is very important and like I I said to
the New York Post embellishment what
does it mean though what does it mean
because the meaning of the word actually
matters in practice
of course it means to to carry yourself
in an honorable way and I made a mistake
and I think humans are flawed and we all
make mistakes Tulsi
um I think we can all look at ourselves
in the mirror and admit that once in our
life we made a mistake I'm having to
admit this in National Television for
the whole country to see and I have the
courage to do so because I believe that
in order to move past this and move
forward and Be an Effective member of
Congress I have to face my mistakes and
I'm facing them
um the reality is is that I remain
committed to doing everything I set
forward in my campaign I'm not a fraud
I'm not a fake I I didn't materialize
from thin air I worked damn hard to get
where I got my entire life life wasn't
easy it didn't start off easy as I've
said it many many times I come from
abject poverty I made some mistakes and
I own up to them and now I want to put
this thing against me so I can deliver
for the American people
the thing is congressman-elect integrity
means yes carrying yourself with honor
but it means it means telling the truth
being a person of integrity and if I
were one of those in New York's Third
District right now now that the election
is over and I'm finding out all of these
lies that you've told not just one
little lie or one little embellishment
these are blatant lies my question is do
you have no shame do you have no shame
in the people who are now you are asking
to trust you to go and be their voice
for them their families and their kids
in Washington
Tulsi I can say the same thing about the
Democrats and and the party look at Joe
Biden Joe Biden's been lying to the
American people for 40 years he's the
president of the United States Democrats
resoundly support him do they have no
shame I've made this very this is not
this is not about the Democratic party
though this is about your relationship
frankly with the people who've entrusted
you to go and and fight for them and I
think one of the questions that that
really probably hits home to a lot of
people is is are you Jewish we've got a
letter that your campaign sent out
earlier this year which reads as follows
as a proud American Jew I've been to
Israel numerous times for educational
business and leisurely trips you said
there in that letter that you are quote
a proud American Jew how do you how do
you explain that
my Heritage is Jewish I've always
identified as Jewish I was raised a
practicing Catholic I think I've gone
through this even I've not not being
raised a practicing Jew I've always
joked with friends and circles even with
in the campaign I'd say guys I'm Jewish
remember I was raised Catholic so look I
understand everybody wants to nitpick at
me I I'm gonna reassure this once and
for all I'm not a facade I'm not a
persona I have an extensive career that
I worked really hard to achieve and I'm
going to deliver from my experience
because I remain committed in delivering
results for the American people I
campaigned on inflation I campaigned on
crime I campaigned on education I
campaigned on delivering resolve for the
American people that's what the people
of the third congressional district
heard me on and on as I campaigned now
it's going to be a incumbent upon me to
deliver on those results and I look
forward to services and serving my my
district I look forward to serving my
people there is my district to make sure
that they see that this is looking for
the results that people are looking for
are called into question when you tell
blatant lies not embellishments and this
is this is I think one of the biggest
concerns Congressman elect is that you
don't really seem to be taking this
seriously you've apologized you said
you've made mistakes but you've outright
lie a lie is not an embellishment on a
resume you said you worked at Goldman
Sachs and Citigroup but they've said
we've got no record of this guy working
for us you've said you've gone to and
graduated from these universities but
they've said well we've got no record of
that these are blatant lies and it calls
into question how your constituents and
the American people can believe anything
that you may say when you are standing
on the floor of the House of
Representatives supposedly fighting for
them that's the real issue here
well look I and I I agree with what
you're saying and as I stated and I
continue
we can debate my my resume and how I
worked with firms such as is it
debatable or is it just false
no is it debatable or is it debatable I
no no it's not false at all it's it's
debatable I can I can sit down and
explain to you what you can do in
private equity in in capital intro via
servicing limited partners and general
partners and we can have this discussion
that's going to go way above the
American people's head but that's not
what I campaigned on I campaigned on
delivering results for the American
people by lowering inflation I can sit
down and if you want to have that
discussion I'd be glad to Tulsi to
explain that to you and make sure that
we we settle the score
that this is not about settling scores
and I think you just you just kind of
highlighted I think my concern the
concern that people at home have you're
saying that this discussion will go way
above the heads of the American people
basically insulting their intelligence
so not only are you now that's not what
I'm saying that you've told but but
you're saying that you can't explain it
in a way that your constituents would
actually be able to I can explain it in
a way to give me the time I can easily
give the if you give me the time I can
easily explain it for you as as in when
investors are looking for Capital and
I'm sitting there doing due diligence on
the decision on the appetite and what
they're looking for right and we work
alongside GPS and LPS to help them place
this Capital this is what I was doing
and that's when I worked extensively
with these firms and many other firms at
my time as I was vice president of
linkbridge investors so this isn't uh
this isn't the made-up narrative but I
feel like nobody really wants to sit
down and talk about it everybody just
want to push me and call me a liar look
Congressman I did
Congressman Alex Santos we've given you
a lot of time I think the time that is
owed is to the people of New York's
third uh it's hard to imagine how they
could possibly trust your explanations
when you're not really even willing to
admit the depth of your deception to
them thank you so much for being here
and joining us subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight